This might be a silly question,
but what do you do with a beached whale?
That's a question.
The small Canadian town of Trout River
is trying to figure out right now,
an 81 foot beast of a whale washed up on
one of his rocky beaches last week as
food and it's humongous.
Stomach begins to rot and decompose.
Bacteria proliferates and that bacteria
in turn begins to feed on the whales.
Inerts microbes called anaerobic
mythology and start to break down
molecules and release methane gas into
the sealed environment,
billowing that fucker up like a birthday
party balloon wait too long and the
whale might explode.
It's a cool concept,
but you don't really want that if you're
trout river bringing and unassuming
gentleman to sort of poke it with a
stick and you're going to get the same
results.
So what do you do?
Well,
you really have two options.
You can either airlift the dead whale
back into the ocean so that its carcass
can feed an entire ecosystem of life for
decades.
Side note,
Radiolab has an awesome animation of how
this process works and you can find that
link in the description or you can bury
the whale somewhere on land.
Both options are going to be really
expensive and that's public money,
Aka tax money,
Aka your mind,
but if you do nothing,
the methane gas along with the ammonia
and hydrogen sulfide are gonna.
Get really smelly really fast.
Side note,
ammonia is the one that smells like cat
piss and hydrogen sulfide is the one
that smells like rotten eggs and is the
part one.
You're gonna have to do something.
Trout River and and before you say
anything,
because I can see the look in your eyes,
don't think about blowing it up.
I mean we tried that already in in
Portland,
Oregon in 1970
that had to be fed.
The Oregon State Highway Division.
Not all had a whale of a problem on a
tab.
Those thudding noises that you hear,
that's thousands of pieces of whale
carcass showering.
Unsuspecting passers by and what I'm
sure still remains the most traumatic
experience of their lives.
Art Car over a quarter of a mile from
the black fight was the target of one
large chunk.
The passenger compartment literally
smack.
Fortunately no human was hit as badly as
the car over.
Everyone on the scene was covered with
small particles of dead.
It just goes to show you can't blow up
all your problems.
Sometimes you have to hunker down and
invent the portal gun.
Are we,
are we working on this?
Fucking him.
You may have noticed that sometimes I'll
disappear for a few weeks or months
without any message of where I've gone
and I'm sorry about that,
but I don't know if you're like this,
but I can't seem to stop jumping to
different projects.
Like I did this sketch comedy channel
called Dick Soap,
which you can check out or the
electronic app,
a new disguises which you listened to on
spotify,
but I'm back for the nerd writer for a
little bit.
Hopefully I'm going to try to separate
it into like season,
so six or 10 episodes.
Um,
and hopefully this is the beginning of a
stretch.
So thanks for sticking with me.
Uh,
and I will see you next time.